Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
and sometimes sex for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are wrapping up Sextember
by answering your questions,
comments, concerns,
celebrations, curiosities
that you sent to us using
#EarBiscuits around Sextember,
which is leaked into October.
Yeah.
It could not be contained.
But we're shutting it down.
And we're gonna be
answering some fun questions
and we'll see where this goes.
Including but not limited
to have we ever experimented
with each other or even thought about it.
Sexually. I mean, we've done lots-
Sexually.
of experiments.
We've done science projects together.
We do that regularly
on the show.
Right.
But have we ever experimented sexually
with each other is a
burning, burning question
that we are going to answer.
Are you referring to when
I gave you gonorrhea?
Yup, super gonorrhea.
As a matter of fact, I still got it.
It's a big problem.
Yup. I'm just glad not
to be alone in it now.
Yeah, so-
I don't actually...
Okay, whatever.
This-
Maybe we'll clarify, do we have gonorrhea?
This whole exercise has
been a lot of fun for me.
We've already expressed the fact
that there was a lot of
trepidation going into this.
Anytime we decide to pull a layer back
and become honest and
vulnerable about something,
especially something that most people
consider to be private.
And like, "Why would you
talk about this publicly?
Do you guys go to parties
and talk about your sexual experiences?"
No, not typically, unless
that's the point of the party.
But again-
I have heard of these parties.
I've never attended one.
Never again.
But the ones that I've heard about,
ultimately, it was about selling sex toys.
It's like a Pampered Chef for dildos.
Yup, yup.
Pampered Dildos.
It's one of my favorite brands.
Not a sponsor yet.
But we did unintentionally write a song
for a sex toy company during
our charity livestream.
Hilarious, man.
Twin Tail Toys, I think,
got their own theme song.
The theme song did not allude to that
because we didn't know
that's what was happening.
Just real quickly,
before we get into this-
last...
You might want to put on do not
disturb on your phone there.
Oh, yeah, let me do that.
Real quick before we get into
this last episode of Sextember,
thank you for all your questions.
Thank you for engaging in
the conversation with us.
Each time we decide to
kind of pull back a layer,
we are confirmed in our belief
that illuminating these things
and being honest and vulnerable about them
is only helpful to the
community around this podcast.
I think it's helpful for us
to kind of be able to share these things.
But what we see is that people are like,
"This led me to think
about myself in this way,"
or, "To breach this conversation,"
not breach but approach this topic
with my partner.
Brooch.
And I just believe
that when you bring an
illuminating light onto something,
the results are positive.
When you try to keep things in the dark,
when you try to keep
things behind closed doors,
the results are just usually not good.
So that's why you're like,
"Why do you guys talk about this stuff?
This just seems like a
unnecessary spectacle
you're doing for attention."
It's like, well, we
know that it gets people
a little bit excited when
we call something Sextember
and talk about sex for a month,
but really the heart behind it,
the intention behind it is to continue
to bring dialogue into a subject
that people are just kind
of afraid to talk about,
that if we would just
have freer conversation
about this stuff,
I think it could be
beneficial to all of us.
I have really enjoyed the conversations.
Especially having Christy and Jessie on,
super proud of them being brave
and breaking the seal
on joining the podcast.
And thanks for all the positive feedback
that you've sent their way.
And I know that they appreciate it too.
And I've appreciated the experience
of just feeling more freedom
associated with this topic.
And it's helped me undo more of,
and let go of even more of the baggage.
I think that is the exercise
of coming out of purity culture for me,
is being able to have these conversations,
identify when there's embarrassment
or shame starts to percolate
and identify it as,
"You know what? Actually, I
don't have to feel that way.
That's not rooted in where I'm at
and where I'm coming from now."
Mm-hmm.
So I've enjoyed
that part of this.
I'm also glad that I haven't said anything
really stupid yet that I regret.
Well, we've got one left.
Okay. Yeah, because we
want this to be helpful
and the last thing I want
to do is like just by...
Again, the disclaimer,
presenting only our experiences,
which we have individual experiences
but they're very close,
and they're very narrow in
the spectrum of experiences
that people have related
to their own sexuality-
Mm-hmm.
and having sex.
And even without the
context of purity culture,
but also within that.
So, that's still what we're
presenting at this point.
This episode will get...
I try as much as I'm
naturally prescriptive
when I talk about things
and I try to be persuasive,
we have tried to stick
with, for the most part,
this is our story.
This is our perspective.
We're gonna try to do
that with these questions
because some of them are just asking us,
"Oh, could you clarify this?
Could you answer this question
about your personal life?"
But some of is, "How do you
think about this thing now?"
And so again, this is our
perspective at this point.
Our perspective has changed
quite a bit-
True.
about so many things over
the course of our lives.
And I expect that it
will continue to change.
It's pretty fluid and it evolves,
but this is where we're
at now on these things.
And I think that, as I said
with Christy and Jessie,
because sex is not the thing that...
It's not just a topic
that comes up all the time
within the the trajectory of
my spiritual deconstruction
and my entire worldview shifting.
I wouldn't say my
lifestyle hasn't shifted,
but the foundations of it have shifted.
Practically, it plays
out pretty similarly.
I'm an evolving Link.
But there's still a lot of
me that's still the same.
But, as I've come to grips
with self-discovery and the new me,
I think that views on
sex lag at least a little
because there's only certain times
when it's appropriate to talk about it.
And it's not as versus other beliefs.
So like, whether that's
how do you interact
with hell or et cetera.
So I will very much acknowledge
I'm still on an active journey
of re-figuring this shit out.
Mm-hmm.
All right. So let's get into it.
KimboJimbo, asked us,
"Do you think your strict
upbringing limiting you
to one sexual partner
for you and your wives
was a good thing now
20 years into marriage,
or do you wish you had more
experience going into it?"
One of the ways that I
processed this question is,
do I want the current
reality to be different?
And that's an easy no.
For me, and this might not
be the case for everybody,
for me, that's no.
I am very happy with my
relationship with Jessie.
I'm very happy with our
sexual relationship.
We have a vibrant and
fulfilling sexual relationship
and our communication about that is open.
And I think our sexual
relationship has evolved
and gotten better over time.
As we said, in the last episode,
I feel like we're having the
best sex that we've ever had.
Now, so the idea of going
back and being like,
"Oh, would you like to
bring more sexual experience
into your marriage?"
My answer is...
Well, I can't answer that question
because I'm happy with how it turned out.
But, again, I don't think that is for me
a prescriptive thing to be like,
"So therefore,
you also should not bring
any sexual experience
and you should also bring complete sexual
or a lot of sexual ignorance
into your relationship
and just figure it out together."
For us, because of the
nature of our relationship
and the nature of our communication style,
and also kind of our sexual disposition,
we were able to grow together
in kind of a beautiful way.
But there's just as many,
if not more examples,
just from my anecdotal
evidence that is out there,
of people who didn't bring
any sexual experience into the marriage,
and then because of some personality stuff
or some specific hangups,
that lack of experience
and lack of comfort
with each other sexually
led to maybe years and years
of sexual non-satisfaction,
or maybe no sex at all.
So I can only speak
from my own experience.
I would not go back and change it.
Yeah. I feel the same way.
I think that because Christy and I were...
We were comfortable really
learning about sex together
and being open and communicative about it.
It didn't end up being a problem.
It actually became fun
for us to learn together.
And I think, you know, I
remember there were these,
like the conversations we
had before our wedding night.
It was like, "Okay, I'm
gonna bring up oral sex."
And it's like, "What if she
says she's grossed out by it?
Like, I'm a little afraid because I mean,
I guess I've heard of that from people.
So, I-
You've heard of oral sex?
I'm really-
I've heard of people
being grossed out by it.
Yeah, people being grossed out by it.
So I'm like, "I really
hope that she's not."
And I remember that moment of like,
I'd rather know now than
have to figure it out
when I'm like, I want to go in for it,
go down on it.
Go down on it, yeah.
And vice versa, and hope for that.
If you're upside down it's going up.
I was relieved that we were
both excited and open to that.
Just, you know, the future
was spread out before us.
So we were compatible in that way.
But if not, that would require more work,
so it was...
We had fun learning each other.
But the fact is we had a lot
to learn about ourselves too.
And it just that made
it part of our story.
I think the other way you could,
maybe this is not the specific question,
but another question that
kind of goes along with it is,
is there regrets just personally?
Like, do I wish I would
have had more experience?
Not so it would have
made me a better lover
or so it would have
helped our relationship,
but it's just like,
"Hey, I only had sex with one woman ever."
I'm curious about that.
I'm curious about what it would be like
to be with another partner.
Of course.
I mean, I just am.
And it's kind of like
when I'm on my death bed and I'm like,
"You know, I never saw the Eiffel Tower."
It's like, well...
Would I have liked to
have seen the Eiffel Tower
if the circumstances were right for that?
Sure.
Well, a better analogy
would be, is there a
famous cave of some kind?
Okay, yeah.
What's the most famous cave in the world?
Because I'm trying to make
it an analogy for a vagina.
You got the Linville Caverns,
which are not that famous.
And I've been to them.
And it was kind of a disappointment.
Okay, see? There you go.
It's like, sometimes
it's not in your mind.
It's built up more.
I've never gone through
that tunnel underneath
the English Channel.
Boy, I'd like to do that.
But you know what,
I'm sitting here dying on my death bed.
That's why it's called a death bed.
It's really just my bed.
But now that I'm dying,
we're calling it a death bed.
And I'm saying, "You know what?
I am grateful for the life I lived.
And I can see the beauty in
the tunnel that I did frequent.
And I can still be honest and say,
"Is the idea of visiting another tunnel
appealing or intriguing?"
Yes, but I have no
regrets in not going there
because, hey, you can't
do everything in life.
You can't see all the sites.
And by seeing those sites,
you don't know what ramifications
that would have in who you are as a person
and your experience.
And it might have really screwed up
the cozy experience that I've come to know
and love and covet,
that is our own tunnel.
Right. Basically, again,
it kind of relates to
the way I was thinking
about the question is like, in the context
of my own personal experience-
Right.
and the tunnel that I frequent.
The prospect of other
tunnels, because I'm a normal,
well, I won't say normal,
because I am a sexually active
and sexually motivated man.
Yes, the idea of other
tunnels is appealing-
And I wouldn't even say
man, let's say person.
Person, well I'm speaking
from my own experience,
is always going to be appealing
and my wife understands that.
We're not one of those couples
that the idea or even a conversation
about being attracted to someone else,
I mean, hell, I dressed up like
Jason Momoa for her birthday
because she is sexually
attracted to Jason Momoa.
And I know that, I get
that, I appreciate that.
And my way of responding to that
was to become Jason Momoa
for her birthday, right?
I thought it was funny.
You know, I played up in
the video that I was like,
I can't believe that I'm
the wing man in this thing.
It's like, this is ridiculous
because it's funny.
I will say in the past,
like years before that
maybe decades earlier,
I would feel uncomfortable
when you and Jessie would talk openly
about your celebrity crushes, for example.
Or saying things in conversation
about how hot you thought
somebody else was.
Mm-hmm.
I came to realize that, for me,
some of that discomfort was...
Well, first of all, I'd realized
that that would translate
into judgment of you.
But that was really...
I came to realize a defense mechanism
covering up the root of my response,
which was tied into abandonment
issues and security issues.
So, I wouldn't wanna...
You know, if Christy brought up something,
it might trigger in me
an insecurity that like,
"Oh, she made a joke about
Keith Urban," you know.
And I'm like, does that scare me?
Does that threaten me?
Does that tap into
something deep inside of me
that like just an honest statement
about acknowledging that
somebody is attractive
all of a sudden means a whole lot to me?
But exploring it leads to growth.
So, I think I've been a little envious
that you can speak openly about that
because you didn't have that hangup.
But it brings up something
that I actually do need to work...
Abandonment issues is
something that I am working on.
But it takes acknowledging that.
And it happened within
that process a little bit.
Of course,
a lot of other things too.
Right.
Getting to a point where you
can have open conversations,
we can be honest about,
within the context of your relationship,
about the human feelings,
desires, and urges you have.
But then acknowledging
that and then saying,
"But this is what I'm doing
because I love and prioritize you,
and this is what the decisions
we've made as a couple."
You know, it's very rewarding
to have those conversations.
It's difficult and it's scary,
but it's better than just
keeping it to yourself,
and then your partner is walking
on eggshells about things.
Yeah.
You know, I just-
Well, in that sacrifice there is a...
Because I think the old Rhett,
who is listening to the
new Rhett, would be like,
"Oh, he's setting himself up to be able
to do whatever he wants to do," right?
Mm-hmm. Literally.
That is not the case.
It's moving to the health framework.
Like I said, it can be a
little bit more complicated
and complex because it
varies from person to person.
That's one of the biggest
shifts that's happened
as my worldview has changed.
Moving from a place
where you believe there
is an objective morality
that applies to everyone
in every circumstance
and it's a one size fits all,
to understanding that
individual decisions...
This is more of a post-modern way
of thinking about things,
but you are a specific person
with a specific perspective
in a specific place in time.
And what's most healthy for you
is not gonna be the same
as it was for somebody else
at a different place and time.
And I just think that the idea that...
That doesn't mean that now
you do whatever you want to
because I'm in the context of
a relationship with Jessie,
and I don't get to do
whatever I want to do, right?
She doesn't get to do
whatever she wants to do
because we are in a relationship
that involves commitment
and compromise, right?
You don't just get to be like,
"I have a desire, therefore,
I go and fulfill it
and that's the end of the story."
It's like, no, everyone has desires
that you need to keep in check.
And that might be understood and explained
in a religious context
for a lot of people.
But that's how civilization functions
is by there being
cooperation and compromise.
So ultimately, the idea of like,
"I've got this thing.
Oh, this seems like it would be fun,
but would it be best?
Would this be good for me?
Would this be good for us?"
Right.
And kind of to piggyback
off of what you're saying,
bringing those things out
into the open and being like,
"Well, this actually does seem fun to me
or this I'm interested in this,"
having that conversation as a couple
so you can at least acknowledge it.
So it's not just something
that's festering and growing
on one side of the relationship
and then somebody breaks it out and says,
"I want to do this."
And you're like, "Well,
I wasn't ready for this."
But you're already
committed to it in your mind
and there's no coming back from it,
that's a problem.
And I think that's why so
often in the relationships
that I've seen, where
people have tried to sort of
redefine the nature of their relationship,
they haven't ended well.
Because the communication
broke down at an early stage
or the compromise ended at some point.
This is some good stuff.
We could do
a whole podcast on that.
Let's go to-
But-
another question.
But first, let's do an ad.
Yeah, why don't you break out
that beautiful bag you have there?
This is the Mythical Grooming line.
We got some lotion in here.
We don't have any lube in here.
A missed opportunity.
We got some clay pomade.
You could probably use this.
Could you use this as a lube,
this hand lotion?
We got some beard balm.
I think a man can masturbate with this.
I'm just trying to stay on...
Jenna's shaking her head.
She's like, "No, no, no.
Don't give that advice."
We've got a lip balm.
I'm not listening to Rhett.
We've got lip balm, two flavors,
Candy Milk and Peculiarly
Perfect Peanut Butter Peppermint.
This is some good stuff.
We've got a brush.
Yeah.
I know you don't brush
your hair.
Don't masturbate with this.
You got some beard oil. Hey, it's oily.
Hey.
I mean, this stuff's all natural,
but I don't think you can
put it in all orifices.
I don't know why I'm talking about it.
I do know why I'm talking about
it because I'm not ashamed.
And there's a Mythical Comb.
I mean, you can get a lot
of this stuff as a set.
You can get them individually.
You can get them on Amazon,
amazon.com/mythical.
And you can go to mythical.com
and get this stuff.
Super proud of our
cruelty-free formulations
that are highly rated.
Check them out. Groom yourself.
Mythical.com.
Okay. MurphyMurphy asks,
"How did you approach 'the
talk' with your kids?"
Well, interestingly, I recorded it.
I recorded my talk.
You.
Let's just break the seal.
I'm gonna play-
Can I...
When you do this, then my
story will not be as good.
So I should tell my story first.
You want to tell your story first?
Yeah because, I mean, you've
got a freaking recording.
I'm not gonna play the whole talk,
I was just gonna-
Of you talking to Locke.
get into the conversation
with it but go ahead.
Yeah. So before we play your recording,
which cannot be topped.
I'll just go ahead and give a precursor.
I remember Christy and I decided,
"Hey, we need to talk
to the kids about sex."
I mean the older kids, Lily and Lincoln.
Lando was too young to have
a detailed conversation
of anything of that nature.
But we were sitting
down at the dinner table
and I don't know if we had agreed
that this was the particular time.
I think I just brought it up.
I was like-
Dinner table, huh?
Yeah. We had eaten dinner
and then the table was cleared
and then I gave Christy a
look if I remember correctly.
You did a sex talk as a family?
Yes.
Without Lando being there.
Yeah. I think Lando was
dismissed from the table.
He wasn't there. Even if he was there,
I don't think he would've cared.
So yeah, Lily and Lincoln
are two years difference.
This is when we lived in the old house,
the previous house when we
had just moved in there.
So this might've been...
Let's see, if this was eight years ago,
they were 10 and eight.
So they were probably 9 and 11.
Because I know that you
told me that Locke was nine
when you had the recorded
conversation with him.
It's 2013, yeah.
So I'm sure we were talking
about it and I was like,
"Oh, shit. I need to have
this conversation too."
Christy and I were talking about it.
Had it at the dinner table.
I don't remember how it started
because I didn't record it.
I wish I would have.
You should have.
Yeah, because if you do it right,
you only have to do it once.
That's not actually true.
And then you just play
it for your other kids.
That's right.
You just play the recording.
Well, the sex talk is
just whatever their...
Our approach was you bring up the topic,
and then as much as they're
interested and curious,
you engage their curiosity and
you answer their questions.
We knew we would kind of feel out
when would be the point
where they were no longer interested.
And then in subsequent conversations-
That's when it gets good
when they don't want to hear it anymore.
They would get more information.
So it was kind of breaking the seal on us
being able to talk about sex
whenever it needed to come up.
it wasn't a one and done deal.
Right, that's a good strategy.
So I know that was our mentality.
I can't remember a lot of what we said,
but I do remember very early on
talking about the mechanics of a penis
goes into a vagina
and then a baby is made in the woman.
And then it started to make sense.
And I do remember using the finger
going into the hole
created in the fist symbol.
You mean the Eiffel Tower
going into the tunnel
underneath the English Channel.
Yes, so-
Really is what
this is about.
I made this symbol.
Could it fit? Probably couldn't.
I think the Eiffel Tower's way too wide.
I looked over at Christy,
and the symbol she was
making was palms over face.
Not what you want.
Head pointed
towards the kitchen table.
Not what you want to communicate.
Just like double face-palm, looking down.
Yeah.
But I was like, "This
is going to be awkward.
Let's go all the way."
And so we were talking about it
and then Christy and I both kinda,
she kinda clarified and
corrected my mistakes.
I was probably not right about everything.
Yeah, it's not a finger.
And they weren't saying anything.
And then we were like,
"Well, what do you think?
Do you have any questions?"
And it was silence until
Lincoln spoke up and said,
"Awkward."
I'm sure it was.
That was it.
But you talking about
anything with your family
is kind of awkward.
Awkward.
Much less sex.
Yeah, I think all of my interactions
have felt like a sex talk with my kids.
So how many sex dinners
have you had since then?
Again, as we talked about last week,
it's more of this mentality
of if sex comes up,
the word shouldn't be
whispered, well, let's just...
These are legitimate questions.
Let's respond to them as you are curious.
Which I think is an excellent approach,
I also thinking that-
Until you get to be a teenager
and then you've got to a
next level, but we can talk
about that next.
Also an excellent approach
is just to record your talk with your kid.
I did this because I thought
that it would be funny
to listen to it later, and
here we are nine years later.
He did give permission, right?
Uh, no.
Oh, yeah.
Not in the time, but yes, now he has.
Yeah.
Yes,
I told Locke that I was
gonna play a portion of this,
he was like, "That's fine."
So, I do want to preface this by saying,
this is August of 2013
and I'm thinking about where
I was at in my spiritual life.
2013 is really the year
when I stopped considering
myself a Christian.
The end of 2012
was when I was having my
most sort of like intense
like I just don't think
I can keep believing this fundamentally,
like the fundamental underpinnings
of Jesus being the son of God
and raising from the dead and all this.
I've been through that whole story.
But kind of what you were saying earlier,
a Christian sexual ethic was...
No, I hadn't for many years,
I have been uncomfortable
with the idea that...
I was uncomfortable with
Christians who believed
that being gay was wrong.
That ship had sailed for both of us.
Right.
But still,
as I thought about my own kids
and I thought about the sex talk,
it was very heteronormative.
Like, I'm going to talk
about a man and a woman.
I'm going to talk about
a penis and a vagina,
and I'm going to talk about procreation
and that's what the talk's gonna be.
And I'm also gonna say...
I'm not gonna play the whole thing,
I'm gonna play a couple of minutes.
It's longer than that.
I also was like, "And this is something
that you should wait to
do until you get married."
I was still saying those
things to Locke at this time,
nine years ago, when
I was presenting this.
So I just wanna acknowledge that,
that I think now a sex
talk would kind of be like,
here's sort of the procreation
side of the sex talk
and how that works
between penis and vagina
and a sperm and an egg and
uterus and all that stuff.
But, hey, here's a different conversation
or an addendum to that conversation
which talks about sexuality and a spectrum
and that kind of thing.
That wasn't where I was at at the time.
And so my sex talk reflects that.
Just wanted to acknowledge that.
Yeah, me too. In the same place.
So I'll just play this.
Okay.
You told mom that you wanted to know
about how a man and a woman make a baby.
What did you say?
What are you wondering about?
How they do it?
It's not like we can just have fun.
It has to form a certain way.
Has to form a certain way.
It has to what?
Form from something.
All right.
Well, you tell me how you think it works.
Maybe somehow they have a baby?
Well, how do you think it happens?
The DNA mixes from them?
How does that happen?
I don't know.
Pause it.
Just guess.
So basically, your sex
talk so far with Locke
is you trying to get him to
tell you how babies are made.
Did you not know?
Yeah. I needed to have some help on that.
It's kind of ironic.
Well, my strategy here was...
I know I'm recording this.
And so this'll be a funny way to start it.
Yeah.
To get his perspective,
but it also gets him
engaged in the conversation,
gets him talking.
Yeah.
How would the DNA mix?
Because that's kind of true.
When they kiss?
Well, okay.
Some physical reaction?
A physical reaction?
No idea.
I have no idea.
Okay.
This is going to blow your mind.
Okay?
Okay.
And it may be a little bit embarrassing
to talk about, but listen, look at me.
You can talk about anything
with me, I'm your dad.
And I know a lot of things.
Okay.
Okay, now, you know that you have a penis.
It's not funny.
You have a penis, right?
Right.
Okay, do girls have a penis?
What do girls have?
They have like...
What do you think they have?
They must have something
like a wiener at least.
Well-
At least.
you know how you have penis,
which is like a little finger down there.
Do you know what they have?
They have like a whole right there?
Yes.
They have a hole called a vagina.
Vagina.
Okay.
And the way that God designed this
is that when a man and woman get married,
they can...
Well, basically, the
easiest way to say this
is the man puts his penis-
The finger.
Inside-
The cave.
of the woman's vagina.
It sounds crazy, doesn't it?
Did you have any idea about this?
No way.
I never thought of this my whole life.
You never thought about this?
I never thought I would have to go...
Now listen, when you get older...
Not right now, but when you get older,
there's something other than pee
that can come out of your penis
and it's called sperm.
What's sperm?
It has your DNA in it.
Okay. I'm not gonna give
you the whole sex talk.
Wow. He thought it was
hilarious, not awkward,
which is great.
I mean, you got over...
Hey, that was a good job.
You know, I think, like
I said, at the beginning,
he had been asking.
I love the fact that you were asking him
the questions because once
you tell him the answer,
you can no longer get the full answer
because it's gonna be
informed by the real answer,
so that's the takeaway.
If I had to do it again,
I would have totally gotten them to commit
in the way that you did
because that was great.
The reason we had the talk
is because Locke has always
been super inquisitive
and was asking lots of questions.
I mean, there were multiple questions
for like multiple months
and Jessie was like,
"We have to have this talk."
And again, as you heard
right there, I was like,
"God. This is how God designed it.
And, you know, when a man and a woman
are in the context of marriage."
I mean, that was...
Again, I wasn't even calling myself
a Christian at that point,
but I was still in a
place where it's like,
"I don't have a new way
of thinking about this.
And so I'm not about to start
telling something different to my kids.
And Jessie was in a
different place as well.
She was still calling herself
a Christian at that time.
Making it just about how babies are made
really simplified it.
And it reinforced just the
whole heteronormative way
of thinking about things that we were...
Yeah, like you said,
very much coming out of,
but it was like,
"Oh, my God. How does it
relate to a sex talk,"
was not the first thing we
were trying to figure out
when you're talking about
our eternal destiny,
you know?
Yeah.
And it was all happening at the same time.
You're right.
That was when I was in the thick of it.
Yeah. And then you think
about the, you know,
Shepherd who was five years younger,
but also very different.
He wasn't asking all
those questions and so-
My kids never asked any questions.
The thing that happened
that sort of having with Shepherd
is there wasn't a moment.
It was more like older
brother and also a household
where we were talking openly about things.
And as lot got older,
talking more openly and it was like,
"Okay, he's here.
And he's witnessing these conversations
and piecing things together."
And so he just kind of figured out
as we talked about things in more detail.
But the interesting thing
is that I think this kind of
ties into some of the stuff
that we talked about
with Jessie and Christy
of how has this conversation evolved
as our framework has evolved.
And I mean, I'm not gonna
answer the question again,
but just briefly, ultimately,
this has turned into a thing
where it's just like,
as opposed to the way that
it was kind of for us,
which is like, you've got
to protect kids from sex
and you've got to protect
your children from...
You got to tell them a
very particular thing,
but you want to kind of keep them
from messing themselves up.
I think that the mentality now is like,
how can I give as much of
the correct information
about sex to my kids?
And how can I...
I'm not saying I'm not
gonna give them advice,
but I'm not telling my kids...
I no longer have the ideological framework
that says you should wait until
you get married to have sex,
but I'm not in a place where
I'm like sex means nothing.
And so therefore, have it
whoever you want to at any time,
no consequences, no questions asked,
but so it's this ongoing conversation
that we continue to have
kind of to your point,
which is this isn't something
that we talked about once.
This is something that we talk
about quite a bit in our house now.
Yeah.
I think it's always fun
to figure out this parenting stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
I think that the girls
said so much great stuff
about parenting.
The philosophy is we can move on.
Andrew asks us,
"Did you have any go-to music
when you started to have sex,
and are there any songs
you've listened to now
when getting it on?"
All right, so a lighter question here.
I was listening to...
This sounds tropish, but
we had a Barry White CD.
Mm-hmm.
It was like greatest hits
and there were certain...
I would put it on at the top.
And then I would have a point of reference
with how involved our
love making session was
by how far we got into the CD.
And it would actually help...
I would pace myself to the
tracks 'cause it's like,
"Oh, I want-"
You thrust to the beat?
Well...
Is that what you mean?
Well, first of all,
Barry White music is absolutely
made to be thrust to.
Yeah. And you can double-time it too.
Oh, my God.
That's what the music is made for.
And it's a brilliant experience.
I mean, he's so good at it.
And his voice-
But it also is a little bit
comical and ironic.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Now.
And so, 'cause that's Mike-
I haven't gone back to
Barry White in a while,
but I might break it back out.
Now, when we started using music
in our sexual, you know, liaisons,
which was reached right
from the beginning.
Like, we had like a little music player
or something on our honeymoon,
for some reason, Gipsy Kings, remember?
Do you know that band?
Oh, yes.
That was just like...
There was something about it
that it wasn't like sort
of like cheesy and ironic
whether or like-
Sensual.
Barry White might be now.
It was,
"This feels like we're on
vacation in a foreign country."
And there's a bunch of people on stage
with a bunch of different instruments,
sort of singing things that
we can't really understand.
We don't want to understand it.
We just want to speak
in the language of love.
I recommend specifically
their album called Love Songs,
which is the one...
We listened to-
Oh, you had Gipsy Kings
pulled up, you got to get ready for this.
Yeah. Love songs starts of with...
♪ Some other words in Spanish ♪
It's perfect.
But we actually don't listen...
Like, we don't do that anymore
'cause we wore that out so much.
This is actually become
a little bit of a...
I'm interested in your perspective.
We haven't talked about this.
I'm interested in your perspective now
because with Spotify playlist,
which I'm not great at collecting things.
And I kind of see playlists
as collecting things
'cause it like takes this effort
and this extra layer of thought.
And so I'm using other people's playlists
and no one ever gets the vibe
that I'm interested in and
Jessie is interested in, right?
Because Jessie and I and Jessie really,
really doesn't want the, like...
♪ This is somebody singing about sex ♪
It's like, it just gets
a little bit like cheesy
and you know what I'm saying?
It can be distracting in the least.
And then there are some
couples that I think-
That's why other languages are great.
We'll use like hard rock music,
something like "Fight Club".
Like that scene in "Fight Club"
where she comes out where the
rubber glove on or whatever.
And they're like listen to them.
In my mind,
they're listening to like
this hard rock music.
We've never done that either.
But then sometimes it can get to like,
if you want to play like Al
Green 'cause it'd be like...
Well, Al Green's not bad.
Actually, he's pretty good.
Sometimes it gets a little too sweet.
Yeah, it's not made for that.
I want-
Specifically.
There's a sweet spot for me,
which is just like, there's
a little bit of sensual
and there's a little bit of sweetness,
but also we're both animals.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's all hard playlist to create.
And I just haven't found it yet.
Are you asking me to create it for you?
No. I'm just asking you like,
what is the genre at this point?
Is it slow jams?
I need to do it
for myself too because
the slow jams that go...
I don't really like that
like '90s slow jams stuff.
Well, then you ended up
getting R. Kelly songs in there
and that's problematic.
And you're like, "Ah, you
can't put, you can't do that."
You don't want R. Kelly songs in there.
I go to the R&B genre
and then if I got to
make a quick decision,
I'll just go back to he soul
playlist within the R&B,
but it's like modern, current.
So you might get-
Give me an artist.
Like Usher?
No, he's not current.
Well, he's 15, 20 years.
Yes.
I'm talking about right now.
Actually current.
Like you got a little bit of scissor,
you got the right song
and then you've got some...
Shit, Beyonce's sister.
I'm embarrassed. I'm sorry.
Solange.
I'm sorry, Solange.
I know you hate that, girl.
And I take it back.
And we know you're listening apparently.
Solange has got some good stuff.
And those things start to...
Lucky Daye with an E on the end.
He's a current R&B artist
that you can get some good stuff from,
but they're not creating entire albums
that are just for sex
like Barry White did.
So I do need to create my own playlist
and I'll share it with you.
And then you can move it around,
you can pace yourself and then measure.
It's like, "All right,
this is how I want to..."
Yeah. I like to think of it like that.
Sometimes you just gotta like...
I mean, don't you do that?
Sometimes you're like,
"All right, slow down, change it up."
Oh, yeah. Well-
Let's keep...
This is not gonna-
I think
what's you're getting at
is the number of songs
helps you understand like
how long you've been going
and make sure that you're
not moving too fast.
Right.
Now, I told you
about my smart situation that I had
with the lights and everything.
So if I say, "Hey, Google,
it's business time."
It does start a playlist that I made.
And it also turns all the lights red-
which is pretty exciting for me.
I feel like I'm in for red.
Everything looks a little bit different.
Yeah.
Well, the internet is
currently out of my house.
So, you have to beat box.
So make sure you save
a sex playlist locally.
So if the internet goes
out, you still got that.
Music is very important
for us because we're...
I mean, the way our house is configured,
it's very nice that our
bedroom is like isolated
from everybody else's bedroom
and the rest of the house.
So I mean, we're running interference
on like kids coming and
knocking on the door
or like hearing us.
And so the music-
But the music...
But the kids know the music
means you're having sex.
I don't know.
We never had a conversation with our kids
about like, "You know,
we have sex, like..."
Christy didn't...
We don't talk to Lily about that now.
I mean, she's out of the
house and it's like...
By the way,
next week is when I'm gonna talk about
the whole experience of Lily leaving home,
sending our first child off to college.
We're not gonna be talking
about sex next week,
but that's gonna be a good one.
So come on back, you sexphines.
Oh, wow.
I don't know if my...
My kids have been very
naive about all that,
but I know we got a friend who's like,
"I tell my kids, 'Mom and
I are going to have sex,'
and that way we don't have to worry
about them knocking on the door."
And I kind of wish I would have done it.
We haven't done that,
but I think our kids know.
And our door doesn't lock, right,
as I've established.
But music has been important,
but last night, Lando was
at your house with Shepherd.
Mm-hmm.
Of course, Lily's gone now.
And Lincoln was at a meeting
and it was the first time at night.
I was like, "Whoa, nobody's
here. It's just us."
It's like, "We don't
even need to play music."
Even though we don't have
internet, played a little music,
but like, we never have
the house to ourselves.
And we have this commitment
to making it work anyway.
But I was like, "Man, I'm gonna to yell."
We were in the midst of it and I'm like,
"I'm me. I can yell at
the top of my lungs."
I was literally sex yelling
because it was the first time-
But you weren't making like-
in, as long as I can remember-
pleasured noises,
you were literally saying
what you just said?
A little bit, but I didn't
say, "This is still free."
I didn't say that.
But I was like, yeah, we talked
during sex and we somehow...
I did it because it was
funny like she was laughing.
I was like, "I can yell at top of my lungs
and no one can hear me.
I'm having sex in my own home.
This is exactly what I
was yelling last night
while having sex."
Well,
your neighbors heard you, which is fine.
I think that married
couples develop a way...
I mean, if you want to
talk about it explicitly,
it's just like-
I do.
the moment of orgasm, which, you know,
can typically be very loud,
married couples with children
have a way of basically climaxing.
And it's just all in the face.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You could definitely like dub this
and you would think
they were making noise,
but really they're just going...
It's like you could put a grunt
and some moans under there,
but they're not doing it
because they've been trained
to not make that much noise,
but then you go on vacation
and there's this adjustment
period to be like,
"Oh no, no, we can make noise now
because our children are not here."
But you've gotten used to...
The sex can be very intense, but still,
you're kind of like mouthing
noises versus making noises.
And I think there's a transition,
especially when the kids leave for good.
I think that we will
become louder and louder.
Yeah. Even last night, I was like,
"Man, we're really missing out on this.
The vocalizations.
Yeah.
It does make a difference.
Warbird asks, "Got a
Sextember question for Rhett.
You are tall and your wife is not,
does this present any sexual challenges
and/or opportunities?"
You know what? I don't
think it presents either.
I'm interested in the opportunities,
but I have not run into the challenges.
Just to be quite frank with you,
and I don't know what it is about.
I mean, I am 6'7" and she is 5'3" but...
Certain things have to line up,
but that means other things won't line up.
Like if you're a twig
and berries are lining up
with the tunnel-
Would you be surprised...
did your mouth gonna lined up?
Would you be surprised to know
that we can be fully connected?
And when I say fully connected,
what I mean is my penis
will be in her vagina.
Great.
And we can be kissing at the same time.
Would you be surprised to
know that that's possible?
Definitely.
Well, we do it all the time.
Are you in like some kind
of cow yoga position?
Think about your necks.
So first of all,
I have a back that can bend a little bit
and I have a head and she has
a head and we both have necks.
And so if I'm bend a little
bit and she's like this,
and I'm like this, mouth-tongue action.
So we're gonna be making out
and screwing at the same time
and do that on a regular basis.
And it has never presented it...
Now, also because your height difference
is over the course of your whole body,
so if there is a...
What is that difference?
A 14, 16 inches difference.
It's spread out proportionally.
Yeah.
It's not like there's
a 16 inches difference
between where my penis and my mouth is.
If your big toe was your penis-
That difference is from my head to my toe.
So I'm only a probably accommodating
for like seven or eight
inches of difference
between my penis any my mouth,
just to get geometric about it.
And then I'm bending and there's...
So, but to answer your question,
is the height difference an issue?
And it has not been an issue for us.
I hear that loud and clear.
All right. Let's talk about us.
Toxic_tonic ask,
"Have you guys ever
experimented with each other
or even thought about it?"
First of all, thanks for asking
because I think that, apparently,
there's a lot of people who
want to know this and speculate
and I don't know if this
is just a Tumblr thing,
but definitely they're-
It's concentrated at level.
They want to like assert it as a reality.
Right. It's beyond speculation.
It's an assertion that
this is a definite reality.
Of course, there's fan
fiction written about us.
That then our crew has gotten
us to read on the show.
The only reason I'm hesitant
to answer this question
is because I actually
think the fact that people
firmly believe that we're
having sex with each other
might be the reason that they're fans.
And so I really appreciate fans.
So I don't want to lose any fans.
Well, I mean, we're
committed to being honest.
Right, we got to do this.
And I want to explore this completely,
but the simple answer,
first, is we have not
experimented with each other.
I've never experimented
with anybody, once-
I've seen your penis a couple of times.
Like we skinny dipped a few times
with friends over the years.
Yeah.
I mean, talking to like high school.
Yeah, I've seen many
of my friends wieners.
You know, we've urinated
next to each other.
I've never seen your erect penis.
I've never seen yours either.
But yeah, it was flacid.
Here's what happened.
When that happened,
I catch a glimpse of it.
Here's what I will say.
The most physical that we
have been with each other,
you've already seen it on the internet.
Definitely.
We've cuddled
with each other.
We've gotten close to kissing each other.
Have we kiss each other on GMM?
I don't know.
No.
I've kissed Chase on GMM.
Right. Well, we like kissed
with glass in between us.
We've kissed with glass in between us.
But it was very quick
and it wasn't something
that we were excited about.
The closest that we've been
to each other, physically,
has been something that
has already been broadcast
on the internet.
And there's photos-
Yeah.
many photos out there of us kissing
that are people taking things
that have happened on GMM-
Photoshop.
and Photoshopping them together
and they're very convincing
and look very real.
Yeah, but we've never done that.
So I'll go a step further and say...
I'll just speak for myself.
Yeah, speak for yourself.
I'll let you speak for yourself.
Yeah.
It's just never crossed my mind.
I mean, honestly, has
never crossed my mind.
I think people who think that we're...
They experience our bond of
friendship and they want it.
They see how meaningful it is.
And the way that I make sense
of it in the fan fiction
is that it's taking
something that is very real,
which is our friendship,
our best friendship bond, and connection,
and there is a friendship
platonic intimacy
associated with that.
And it is an unusual and very
intense and long friendship.
Absolutely.
And then people want to say, well...
For some people to make sense of that,
they say that there must be an unspoken
or not public romantic
attraction sexual element.
From my perspective,
it's just never crossed my mind.
I've never observed desires
welling up within myself
of attraction to you.
I gotta say I'm a little disappointed.
I'm sorry.
But I will say-
I do a lot
to try to make myself attractive.
But that statement also
applies to any other guy,
straight, gay, whatever.
I've never observed within myself-
You're not even attracted
to like Jude Law?
No, no, I'm not.
I have not experienced any
sexual attraction to another guy.
And I think people who
see our relationship,
they just, they want to make sense of it.
But people also desire for...
Because we have this intimate friendship,
they desire for it...
There's a fantasy that
for it to go all the way.
It has to be romantic, if not sexual.
Yeah.
And-
I mean, actually, I don't know.
I don't know either, but I do think
that it's an opportunity to say,
"You know what?
You can be in a devoted
intimate friendship
and it never come close
to having a romantic
or sexual element because that's
exactly what's happening."
And I think that is something
that we're very proud of
and that we've come to grips
with being a cornerstone
of why people want to enjoy our-
When you say "proud of" what do you mean?
I'm proud of-
You're not proud of not being gay.
No, I am proud of being
unabashedly your intimate friend.
Yeah.
Of being your best friend.
Like there's a vulnerability in saying,
"You're my best friend.
I love you as a friend."
And there's nothing that
you can do to change that.
That we have a bond unlike anybody else,
but it doesn't have to
be a romantic or sexual
for it to be extremely meaningful.
And I'm very proud of what we have.
Right. And I think that's an a-
But it's different.
It's an important point
that you're making,
which is because if you
assume that in order to really
be bonded with someone-
Right.
it has to be romantic
and it has to be sexual.
What you're doing is you're
discounting the intimacy
that can come from a platonic connection,
which is what we have
as like a brotherhood,
a literal blood bond,
like not literal brothers,
but we did-
But there was an oath.
We did a blood oath.
And I find that...
And I'm not gonna assume
where that comes from
because that's not me
and I don't know exactly why it happens.
And again, there's a part of me
that I think, maybe 10 years ago,
there was a part of me that
was a little irked by it
because I was like,
"I don't want people to think we're gay."
I'll speak to that too but go ahead.
That bothers me for some reason
that I haven't quite explored.
Now, I'm in a place where I'm like,
"Wow, the people think that we're gay
and that makes them like us more
and want to connect with us even more,"
then so be it, maybe
that's good for the brand.
But again, that's why
I was a little hesitant
to answer the question,
but to be honest and to disclose the fact
that no, I don't think there's...
There would be nothing wrong with us
being attracted to each other.
There would be nothing...
It would be complicated.
We'd have to figure that out.
But no, it's not a reality.
And I'll get into like some...
I'll get into a little bit more
of my own sexuality in a second,
but it sounds like you want
to talk to that at one point.
Well, I think that we're able to have
as deep of a friendship bond as we do
because our desires are in the same place.
We're very compatible in that way.
I agree, there will be nothing wrong
if one of us had a tinge of
attraction for the other one
or had a desire for something more
that the other guy didn't
want or vice versa.
And then we just had to work through it,
but it would create a little
bit of incompatibilities
in our hopes and desires for what we have,
but we don't have that.
So I think that has been another...
That's played out in terms
of us being able to be secure
and celebrate our friendship
because our desires are the same.
Yeah, agreed.
Now, there is a part of me that, you know,
as I have evolved in terms
of my worldview over time,
first of all, coming
from a purity culture,
coming from a place where
the idea of being gay
was something that not only was it wrong,
but it was like, "Oh, that's gross."
Like that was the environment
that we were raised in,
right?
Yes.
And so it was unappealing.
Like you didn't want to
even entertain the idea
that you might...
In fact, I remember in high school,
there was a kid who
started spreading a rumor
that me and you were gay.
I don't know if you remember this.
I vaguely remember.
I think it's freshman year.
And I was so upset about that
and ended up being this thing
that we had to go to the
principal and talk to him.
Really?
Yeah.
He started writing like,
"Rhett and Link love each other,"
or something like on desks or in bathrooms
or something like that.
And like, I confronted
him about it and then...
So all that to say, I, as my
Christian worldview fell away,
I was like, "Well, I want
to like, literally be...
I want to be honest with myself."
Like, have I been pushing something down
because of my background and the fact
that it wasn't okay to
be attracted to men.
So therefore, I wasn't
willing to entertain
the idea of being attracted
to men because I'm like,
if I'm just honest with myself,
there was never a point...
And I used the Jude Law as an example.
It's kind of a joke,
but like a handsome man like that,
I can recognize when a man is handsome.
But there was never a
point in which I was like,
"And I want to kiss him."
Or, "And I want to be
close with him sexually."
Like that has never crossed
my mind, but I was like,
am I repressing something, right?
And so I don't remember
the first time this was,
but I mean, it's been years.
I was like, "I'm gonna
watch some gay porn."
Okay.
I'm like, "I'm gonna do it."
I'm gonna watch two
dudes screw each other.
Not only am I a little bit interested.
I mean, I got it. I know how it works.
I know that the penis goes into the butt.
I know that's how it works,
but I kind of, you know,
like, let's watch that happen
and let's get some on the
scale of attractiveness.
Let's get some attractive men
and let's watch them have sex
and see if it does anything for us.
Like literally, this is
something that I have done
and I watched it and was because...
Here, okay.
Backing up a little bit.
We're gonna talk about porn in a second.
But my experience with
porn had always been,
"Oh, I'm into watching two women
have sex with each other."
That's the porn that I like.
I don't want to not see that penis.
Okay.
And again, I was like,
is this something repressed?
Like, why did I have a
problem with a penis?
Am I afraid that I'm gonna
see a penis and be like,
"I want that penis."
Mm-hmm.
And so this was like
a personal exploration
into this for myself.
And when I watched it, I was like,
"This is interesting."
Those guys look better than I do,
but I do not have a desire to be there.
I do not have a desire to be one of them.
I don't find myself
being sexually turned on
and wanting to be a part of this.
You didn't bookmark it.
I did not bookmark it.
And you know, at this point in my life,
I'm okay with seeing a penis, right?
There's not like an aversion
or "I'm scared of seeing it",
but it's like, as far as I know,
I have plumbed the depths of myself
and come back with "I'm
attracted to women".
Now, one of the things that
I have learned about myself
and I haven't done a lot
of research about this,
and I'm sorry if I get terms wrong,
and this is always, you know,
but I am attracted to transwomen, right?
So transwomen are women,
that makes sense that I
would be attracted to women.
I get that. Sure.
But a transwoman with a penis...
So I've already established
how much I like vaginas
and, specifically, vulvas.
I believe that it is
almost like the universe
we've been down that road.
I won't go down that road again.
So yes, I prefer a penis...
Freudian slip.
I prefer a vagina over a penis.
But the thing is,
is I think that what I'm
ultimately attract...
If I was, and this isn't about to happen,
I'm in a happy relationship with my wife,
but let's just say I wasn't.
And there was someone who was a transwoman
that I was attracted to
because I think I'm attracted
to sort of feminine traits
and the feminine presentation of someone.
And I was like,
"Man, I'm attracted to
this person sexually."
And we get along or whatever,
and then I find out,
"Oh, she has a penis."
I'd be like,
"Well, I don't like a
penis as much as a vagina,
but would this be the end of the world?"
And this would be something
that necessarily a showstopper.
Honestly, I don't know.
I kinda think I would
really miss the vagina,
but it's not really the penis
that's the issue for me,
it's the fact that I'm
just not attracted to men.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I was just trying to think
of like my own experience
'cause I just haven't
thought about this stuff.
I had just haven't been as
specifically curious about it.
So again, it's like, for me,
it's like I haven't observed
those desires welling up
or the curiosity to find out or feel like,
am I suppressing anything?
It's like, you know, it doesn't.
I'm very happy and I'm not...
I just haven't found myself being curious
about whether I'm suppressing anything,
but I feel pretty damn sure that I'm not
because I value being
very open with myself
and plumbing the depths of what's in me.
Yeah. And well, so I guess all that-
But I get all that.
I think it's cool, man.
I guess all that to say
that we've never
experimented with each other
and we haven't thought about it.
And-
I think-
You know, and I don't
know what this is gonna do
for the people out there who just...
I will say, again,
actually, I'm not offended
and I'm not hurt by it.
But I will say that in general,
the idea of insisting and assuming
someone's sexual orientation
despite what they say,
like, that's not cool.
No, it's not.
So switch that around and be like,
you got somebody who's
telling you that you're gay.
And you're like, no, you're not.
You're not gay.
You're straight. I know you're straight.
You think about it like that,
that's not a cool thing to do.
Individuals assert their own sexuality.
You don't assert someone else's sexuality.
Again, I know we're public figures
and it's fun for some people.
Don't stop writing the fan fiction
if you don't want to stop it,
but I wouldn't make a habit
of asserting or assuming
someone's sexuality
if they are telling you something else.
That's a not cool thing to do.
I think one of my journeys
that maybe can be observed,
I believe it can be observed
online that you described it.
I also wanted to weigh in on was, yeah,
coming from where we came from
and like our fundamentalist beliefs
about being gay, being wrong.
And so I was unwilling to
make any jokes about that
or to flirt with any
humor around that area
between the two of us.
And once I became very accepting
and removed that judgment
from my own life and mind
and that made me more secure in who I am
and saying,
"I'm not afraid if somebody
thinks that I'm gay
or we're gay because I don't.
It's not anything to
be embarrassed about."
Right.
And that was a shift that...
That was a journey where I
had to get to that point.
And I'm very glad I got to that point,
a by-product of it was
that then we could explore
that relational tension for humor.
That if people are assuming these things,
or if we're as close as we are,
like us exploring the
tension for comedy is funny
because there's no stakes.
If people think that we're gay, who cares?
So what? It's what I've thought.
Again, it's another freedom of like,
we can have fun in that area as well,
when it comes to comedy.
But we also don't, and again,
I'm not super schooled on this,
but like, we don't want to get
into queer baiting as well, right?
And I know that queer baiting
can mean a couple of different things.
I've heard it defined a
couple of different ways,
but ultimately, we don't want to use
someone's assumption that we're gay
to get you to click on something.
But like, we will play around with the...
We know that like two straight dudes
doing gay things or gay-ish things
like when the Kanye and
Kim video on the motorcycle
and then with Seth Rogen
and James Franco like-
And James Franco.
did their thing,.
It was like there's a reason...
Comedy doers have done this for years.
Just like straight comedy duos
have done gay-ish type things for comedy.
And I haven't really
thought about that too much
and explored that,
but I don't want to get into a place
where we're like the fact
that you think we're gay
like we're trying to capitalize on that.
No, ironically, we're
comfortable, you know, being...
I just don't even know
how to characterize it
'cause it's kind of instinctual,
but it was something that was like
because we celebrate the
validity of being gay
and then other things as well now, right?
All of it.
Yeah.
I accept the validity of all of it.
That then it gives me a freedom to say,
"Okay, I don't need to try to act
like I'm afraid that you're gonna think
I'm something."
No, we can just have fun with this
because it's just part of...
It's an aspect of humanity.
Yeah.
So it's freedom,
but we are never making fun
of a sexual orientation.
We're making fun of two...
If we're doing that like when we cuddle,
the reason that seems funny to us
is that, well, we don't cuddle, right?
So when two guys who
don't cuddle do cuddle-
Right.
The awkwardness is funny,
right?
Right.
We don't think about
it much more than that.
Yeah.
So hopefully,
that answers that question.
Do with that what you will.
Last question from
Sextember Burner Account.
I get it.
Someone had created a burner
account for this question.
"Since y'all have talked about porn a lot
in terms of growing up, how
do you feel about porn now?
Especially with the gradual
destigmatization..."
Destigmatization.
Destigmatization of sex work
and usage of things like OnlyFans.
Great question.
I mean, definitely when it comes to...
There's a lot that...
Like, I personally haven't
given too much thought.
This is still something
that's evolving for me.
And it's not something that
I've generated a lot of energy
towards like figuring out like my stance.
So I just want to go ahead
and say that up front.
I do think that comes from
being steeped in teaching.
That is like fear porn period.
Like stay as far away
from porn as you can.
It is dangerous.
Like the only messages
that I got related to porn
were negative.
Right.
So even to this point, I
haven't been really motivated
to explore the positive and
empowering aspect of porn
because I, personally,
I just haven't been motivated to do that
because I've been steeped in this.
I know that you can...
It can be addictive
and that it can serve an
unhealthy role in your life,
especially when it relates
to your sex life with your partner.
And it can impact that in a negative way.
So I'm like, I don't find
myself being really motivated
to figure out how to really come to grips
with porn, personally, because
I want to devote my energies
more to like cultivating my
relationship with Christy.
Right.
And everything
that we've been presented
with within the church
has only been negative.
And when they would talk about it,
it would be about the addiction.
And you would have guys who
would talk about it publicly,
but they would talk about
it within the context
of a former addiction that
they have been released from
and now are currently being protected from
and protecting themselves from.
And a lot of our accountability.
You would have somebody
who was like your accountability partner,
or you were accountable to each other.
Like if you looked at porn, it was bad.
This was like the number one thing
that Christian dudes are like
confessing to each other.
Yeah.
It is,
"Oh, I looked at porn again."
It became a very heated
fixation to stay away from it
like masturbation, but
it was even more obvious
and felt like very deadly.
But I have this sneaking suspicion
that you can't just apply those principles
as a blanket statement.
Yeah.
I mean, it's just like the
vilification of alcohol.
It's like saying that you
can't consume alcohol at all
because you will be addicted.
Well, everybody is not
addicted to alcohol.
Everybody's not addicted to gambling.
I think it's a really good analogy.
But I don't want to...
So I am open to that also
being true of pornography.
Well, that's one of the beautiful things
about abandoning a world view.
It's not easy. It was tough.
It was the toughest thing I've ever done,
but the sort of being able
to examine something new
in a new light in on its
own face and, you know.
And I think that I have
thought a little about this
and I've not extensively
and I haven't like read
a whole lot about it,
I don't have a lot of research,
but I kind of see this as...
There's three aspects of this, right?
There's the nature of porn itself.
And then there's your personal
relationship with porn
and then there's porn as it relates
to your relationship with
your significant other.
So the first aspect...
I'm gonna talk a whole lot about,
but I do think that...
You know, there's an ethical
porn movement right now,
and more and more people
are being sort of...
Because, traditionally,
there was a lot of people involved in porn
who were kind of being coerced.
There was people who were sex trafficked
and then brought into porn.
I don't know what the statistics are,
but I know that there was
an unhealthy environment.
And maybe I say continues to
be an unhealthy environment
and maybe not a lot of consent
involved in some coercion,
but we are kind of moving into a place
where there's more of sort
of a personally empowered,
whether that be like cam girls or OnlyFans
or that kind of thing,
where it's just like,
"Hey, I'm a sex worker.
I'm presenting myself in a
pornographic way to my fans.
No one's forcing me into this.
I'm doing it. It's... "
I am in control.
So I think that I'm all for ethical porn
and how that's parsed is not something
that I'm an expert in,
but I would say that I do believe
that when it comes to issues of health,
again, it's a health framework,
not a moral framework for me.
Yeah.
And so is there a way for
somebody to be a sex worker
in that way, in a healthy way?
I think, yes.
And is there a way, so if
you're watching porn that is...
You can make choices that
will support empowerment
or support the negative
aspects of the industry,
which is and I don't
know how much of that,
but I think, again, I
don't know how much is bad.
but you can make an ethical investigation
and then make a decision where you consume
the porn-
I do think it's important.
that supports a healthy industry.
But the thing is more interesting to me
is your personal relationship with porn
and then your relationship
as in the context of a relationship.
We'll probably have to pay
for that porn, I'm assuming.
I don't know.
Maybe?
Well, yeah. Like OnlyFans
or whatever, yeah.
So again, this is sort of
an evidence-based approach
to this and not coming from
the evangelical mindset.
One thing I do know for
a fact is that the access
that we have to sexually explicit images,
videos, experiences that we
can visually interact with,
or maybe even interact
with in like a VR setting,
like we can have a sensory experience.
It's not something that our brains
adapted to be able to handle.
Our brains and our bodies
evolved in the context of,
you know, again, this
is stone age hardware,
and then we've got the modern day software
that's running on them.
And I think that your brain
is not really equipped
to see 500 vaginas over
the course of a week.
Okay?
Mm-hmm.
Now-
In one video?
Well, there's probably one.
Wow.
It's probably an orgy
video with 500 people.
I don't know what the record is.
But I do think that there
is something to the idea
that extreme visual sexual experience
and sort of sensory experience,
I don't know if we've quite
figured out the impact
that that is having on
us culturally, right?
And it's having on us as people,
there are plenty of people
who will say that, listen,
yes, you can get addicted to this.
Yes, you can replace a
healthy sexual interaction
in person with a online
only sexual relationship,
but there's also things like
expectations for your partner.
If I'm having sex with my wife,
but I am having sexual experiences
with all these other women out there,
and basically, anything that
I could ever possibly imagine.
For me, personally,
it's kind of impossible for me
not to carry some expectations
into my relationship with Jessie, right?
So does that mean that porn is
completely off limits for me?
No.
Does it mean that I'm gonna look at it
whenever I want, whenever I get the urge?
No because I do believe that I don't think
that's gonna have a great
effect on me personally.
So kind of where I stand on the issue
in terms of like how I interact with it
is just like, have I
sworn off porn altogether?
No.
If I am gonna look...
Can I look at it by myself
in the context of my marriage with Jessie?
Yes.
Can she look at it by herself
in the context of our marriage?
Yes, she can.
But is it something that
is gonna be a regular thing
that replaces my sexual
interaction with Jessie?
No because I have a limited
amount of sexual energy.
I mean, I like to think of myself
as having a lot of sexual energy,
but I have a limited
amount of sexual energy.
And am I gonna be devoting that to myself
and this sort of intimate experience
with someone on a screen
when I have someone who, "Oh,
this could be something...
This energy is something I could devote
and direct towards Jessie."
So you got to be careful about that.
At least I do, right?
That makes sense to me,
like the alcohol example.
There's lots of things, as a
responsible autonomous person,
I got to figure out what
is a healthy relationship
with all types of things
that can be very unhealthy
and addictive.
Yeah.
And I think it's interesting, you know,
as we came up in a different time
where we have basically
been through puberty
and-
Right.
we're almost sexually active
like getting married by the
time like porn became this thing
and definitely you could
get it on your phone
and you could see any kind of sexual act
that you want to on your phone.
Like that's a new thing.
Our kids are coming up
in the context of that.
Exactly.
So we talk about that.
It's a totally different
conversation that we had.
I'm not trying to attach shame to it,
but I just want you to understand
that like if your only
sexual outlet is porn,
you know, I do think it's a
generational issue right now
where there's just so many
kids who are experiencing
their only sexual experience
is not an interpersonal thing,
it's a internet thing.
And I haven't done the research
and I don't know all the stats,
but my inclination
is that that's not a good
thing for us culturally.
Is that we need to be making
connections with each other,
but speaking of the
and is there a role for porn
in the context of a healthy relationship?
I think, maybe.
Again, I think that
this is based on consent
and this is based on agreement
between you and your partner.
And I will say that on a few occasions,
Jessie and I have experimented with like,
what would it be like for
us to look at porn together
as we are about to or as we are engaging
in sex with each other.
And it's something we've done
a couple of times, few times,
and it's been pretty cool.
And also most of the time, it's
like, we've kind of like...
It's been humorous as
we've kind of like laughed
because porn tends to be kind of funny,
even when they're trying not to be,
but it could be the kind of thing.
It's just like, "Hey, let's
do what they're doing.
Oh, let's imitate what they're doing."
To me, there's an element of it.
That's just like it
creates sort of an openness
around the idea of sex
and can be a fun addition
to the sexual menu that
you have with your partner.
But it isn't the kind of thing-
It can inspire.
Yeah.
But again, that was a
decision that we made
that I don't even know who brought it up.
And I don't even remember.
I think the time that it finally happened,
it may have been...
I don't want to speak for Jessie.
I don't remember how it happened,
but it wasn't like me like
sitting around me like,
"You want to watch porn today?
You want to watch porn together?
I want to watch porn together with you."
And I definitely don't use that voice ever
with my wife.
Gross.
Yeah, it's not something
that Christy and I
have ever, ever done
because it's just something
that hasn't come up.
My main point about porn is that
because you can interact with porn
and have a fully self-contained
sexual experience,
introducing that into a relationship,
I believe you can run the risk
of becoming dependent upon that
and not having an
experience with one another,
whether that means you're engaging in porn
and masturbation apart from your partner
and directing your sexual energy there.
And so therefore, you're not
giving it to your partner
or you're now together
in experiencing porn,
but all your attention is being directed
towards the screen versus the other person
and something about
the intimacy is broken.
So I'm not saying I've
got to figure it out
and that my way is better.
I'm just-
Well, I think you got it
figured out for you.
Well, I don't even know that.
Me and Jessie may decide
that we don't want that at all.
And the moment
that she tells me-
Right.
"I'm not comfortable with this.
I don't like this anymore,"
is the moment that I say,
"Well, we don't do it anymore."
Right.
And so the conversations that we have,
I hope inspire partners
listening to have conversations,
but more so than inspire
people to do the things
that we're doing or not doing.
Right.
It's more about that
communication, like you said.
I don't want you to be like,
"Well, now we gotta do this
because you said that you did it."
Right.
It's about that.
I mean, first of all,
the questions about porn,
and I think we answered it,
that there is such a
thing as ethical porn.
We do think that there are pitfalls
when it comes to porn personally,
and there are pitfalls when
it comes to porn relationally,
but also it can be an
enhancement in a lot of ways,
but it's complicated, it's complex.
And it's-
You can't paint it
with a broad brush.
Yeah, no.
It's individual.
And it's also the consent aspect,
both in terms of porn itself.
Like, are the people who
are doing these things,
are they consenting to the situation?
But also in the context
of your relationship,
is there consent and
understanding and communication?
If you make sure you're on
the right side of the issue
when it comes to all those things,
you just avoid so many pitfalls.
We haven't even talked about parenting.
I don't want to go too deep into this,
but I do want to acknowledge
that as kids get older
and they go through puberty,
you find yourself having to deal with,
okay, porn is such a...
It just emanates from everywhere.
And you can't just be "do not
have anything to do with it,
never see it".
Oh, because that's not
gonna be successful.
It's just not going to be successful.
You have to figure out a way to say,
"These are the dangers associated with it.
You're not gonna be able
to avoid it entirely,
but you need to maintain your own power
and not give that over to pornography."
For me, that is...
When I'm not just like saying,
"It's bad and I don't
want to be a part of it."
But when I say,
"Well, maybe there's
aspects of it that are good.
And I actually need to engage with it
and process that,"
to me, that actually cuts down
on my total consumption of it
because it makes me engage
with it in a thoughtful way.
Yes.
And I think that-
As opposed to just-
If you just tell your kids
it's wrong, they're gonna do it anyway.
And they're gonna feel guilty
and they're never gonna talk to about it.
And they're gonna keep doing it
and they're gonna potentially
become reliant on it.
Right.
And I...
I think that principle could apply
in terms of like conversations
with your partner as well.
But back to the kids, I mean,
yes, I put filters on my kid's internet
so that they couldn't stumble on porn
or they couldn't get to
it if they were curious
and they wanted to.
But at a certain age, you start to realize
that they're gonna find a way to see it
even if they can't see it on everything
that you have control over in your house.
Yeah.
And so you have to go further,
you have to have these open conversations.
When it starts with,
"I'm putting this thing on your computer
and your phone that..."
We use Kaspersky Kids Safe app.
And it worked really well,
but that's to protect kids
until they get to an age where it's like,
now you're gonna see it.
And you got to figure
out how to deal with it.
And we got to have that conversation.
You just can't have a filter on,
make them have a filter for
the rest of their lives.
They're gonna have to make
that decision for themselves.
Yeah. And yeah, I think that...
I don't know.
To me, it's one of the
most exciting things.
It requires more effort, honestly,
just like we were saying
with Jessie and Christy,
it was easier as an evangelical
Christian to be like,
"Here's the framework
that has been figured out,
and I'm gonna just
put it down on you."
Right.
And that's easier from
a parenting standpoint,
but the like, "Hey, let's
actually engage with this.
You're an individual.
You have certain inclinations
and you're a certain type of person.
How will you interact with this thing?"
Whatever it might be.
Yup.
Can we have an ongoing
conversation about that
and what's healthy for you?
It makes it different from kid to kid,
the relationships and the opportunities.
The inclinations are
different from child to child.
And it just becomes more
involved and it takes more time.
And it's more process-oriented
than it is sort of rule-oriented.
But it's the only way I
know to do it at this point,
but yeah, that's porn.
Okay. And that's our last question.
So, I mean, do you have a rec?
'Cause I wasn't gonna piggyback on that,
but what's your rec?
I have a rec that, again,
my recs tend to not be related
to what we're talking about,
which may or may not be satisfying.
So if you have a rec that is related
to what we're talking about-
Yeah, I was gonna-
why don't you give that?
I'll say mine.
I think I've rec
this before or said it.
So yeah, I'm gonna
recommend mypleasure.com
because it's an educational website
where you can buy sex toys of all types,
and you can read from qualified people,
including doctors, I believe,
about how to use these
things appropriately.
And it's a great educational site that
then if you want to sidestep
the pornography part of it,
that's the principle of the site
is that there's none of that.
So it's separate.
'Cause we didn't talk a lot about-
Separates porn from sex toys
and it simplifies that equation.
And you can be educated
and be adventurous.
Yeah, 'cause we didn't talk
a lot about toys.
Mypleasure.com
I mean, we talked about toys incidentally,
but we're both very big
proponents of sex toys.
I mean, again, when you've
been married for 20 years,
one of the ways that you
continue to keep things spicy
is you introduce new
things into the bedroom.
And that's one of the great
things about growing old-
You want to make that your rec, Rhett?
learn about yourself and your partner.
Yeah. So yeah,
I'm on board for My Pleasure
and I'll just do my other rec next week.
Okay.
In the meantime,
we do want to remind you
about Good Mythical Evening.
Again, we've been talking a lot about sex.
We're gonna talk about sex
on Good Mythical Evening,
and we're gonna do a lot of other things.
Adult stuff.
It is the adult-themed ticketed live event
on October 28th,
you can get tickets at
goodmythicalevening.com.
It's a Good Mythical Morning.
We're just all censorship removed.
Yeah, which is something we're
not able to do on YouTube.
And that's not something
we don't want to change
what Good Mythical Morning is.
But this will be fun.
But we want to do something
a little bit different
just on Good Mythical Evening.
GoodMythicalEvening.com.
#EarBiscuits, let us know
as we wrapped up Sextember,
what you think about it?
And we'll talk at you next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.